two of the three people accused of
holding two teenagers captive are no
longer in jail this is an update to a
story the eight news now investigators
have been following very closely the
teen's grandmother aunt and boyfriend
were indicted on a number of child abuse
charges now a judge set bail earlier
Monday as high as 75 thousand dollars
for the ant she and the grandmother did
manage to post bond in fact this is the
grandmother in court today the boyfriend
though remains in jail for a look at the
evidence obtained we have more about how
the teens were eventually rescued you
can go to our website at 8newsnow.com